FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi and
welcome to a episode number
46 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hi, Mark.
How excited are you today?
MARK MANDEL: I'm pretty excited.
I'm pretty excited.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Today we have the
incredible honor
to have John Wilkes
as our interviewee.
And yeah, Mark is
very, very excited.
MARK MANDEL: I'm pretty--
I'm pretty excited.
I am.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm also
very excited, to be honest.
So we're going to
be talking with him
about the history of Borg and
how, basically, Borg gave birth
to Kubernetes, what is the
relationship in between,
and other random things.
He's pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, he is.
Yeah, I'm pretty excited.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
He's very excited.
And after that, we will go with
our question of the week, which
is actually quite simple, but
not many people know about it,
so I thought it
was worth talking
about-- which is, OK, I
love application default
credentials.
If you haven't heard
about it, we'll
discuss a little bit what it is,
but how do you use it locally?
There's an incredibly
easy way to do it.
MARK MANDEL: It's very cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So yeah, that will
be at the end of the episode.
But now we're going to go
first with the cool things
of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so we
have some great cool things
of the week this time around.
We had a pretty
busy week this week,
with a few things coming out.
Just want to highlight, I
think, a couple of my favorites.
First one being is, we
have some new regions
coming in 2017, which I
think is pretty exciting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
some of them-- actually,
this really feels like a good
list of places I should visit.
So we have London,
that I know already,
but Finland, and Frankfurt,
never been there.
Sao Paolo, Sydney, I think
that's in Australia--
MARK MANDEL: In Australia, yeah.
That's something else that I
think is going to be great.
Might have to go
down to Australia
sometime around that opening.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
sounds like a great event.
And also Mumbai, and Singapore,
and Northern Virginia.
So a bunch of new regions
to be announced next year.
This was actually
announced during--
MARK MANDEL: Horizon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Horizon.
So we'll have a link through
to all the announcements
that happened in
Horizon, because there
were a lot of them.
MARK MANDEL: There were a
lot of them, absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
there was also one thing
that you were involved with.
MARK MANDEL: Well, I was
loosely involved with.
I think that's maybe
a little stretch.
But we finally got a
blog post out about how
Pokemon Go runs on the
Google cloud platform, which
is really, really cool.
So we talk a little
bit in that blog post
about how they use data store
for state management, how
they have one of the
biggest GKE clusters ever.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The, the.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
actually, yeah,
the biggest GKE cluster ever.
Possibly the
biggest communities.
Nobody knows.
I don't know.
A supposition all around.
And there's some
graphs in there.
And they talk about
the new Customer
Reliability Engineering team
and how that works too--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Which is really cool.
MARK MANDEL: Which
is also really cool.
Hopefully we can get
them on the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I would love to.
MARK MANDEL: I would
love to do that too.
But yeah, definitely
worth a read,
especially if you
play Pokemon Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, my
favorite thing about it
is that little graph that shows.
So yeah, we were expecting to
have this mountain of traffic.
So we bought 5,000 more.
But after 15 minutes
that was already gone.
And we've reach 50%, 50
times more than we expected,
like, ouch.
Yes.
It was 50 times more
than what they thought
they were going to
have and 10 times more
than their worst case scenario.
So it was an enormous
amount of traffic.
A huge, huge global sensation.
Yeah, really, really
awesome [INAUDIBLE].
So we'll have a link
on the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So why don't we go do my
favorite thing for this episode
and go have a chat with John?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So excited.
Let's to that.
MARK MANDEL: Today I am
greatly delighted to be
joined by John Wilkes
here together with us
on the podcast.
How are you doing today, John?
JOHN WILKES: I'm good.
I'm delightfully grateful
for having me on.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
For those people
who don't know who
you are, whoever
those people may be--
I've been following
your stuff for ages
and been a huge fan of
yours for a very long time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Mark is incredibly
excited about this episode.
MARK MANDEL: I am.
Please, can you tell us a
little bit about yourself,
what do you do here at Google?
JOHN WILKES: I'm just this guy.
I work in the Borg
team, which is
part of our technical
infrastructure folk.
We write software that runs
a fleet of machines that
runs across-- pretty much
every other stuff that
runs inside Google
runs on top of us,
so, from the outside world,
Google Compute Engine,
and pretty much all the cloud
products run on top of Borg.
Borg runs on top
a set of machines.
Borg allocates those
machines on demand
when people come along
and say, you know,
I need 4,000 places to run this.
Could you find
those 4,000 places?
We'll pick them.
We will cope with the fact
that three of them will break.
We'll put them somewhere else.
We'll work out how else
we can patch things
into these clusters of
machines to make them used
as efficiently as possible.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So one
question that-- I've
been working at Google
for quite a while,
but I'm actually not
sure about the answer.
For how long we've had Borg?
Did we create it from
the beginning, or?
JOHN WILKES: We started it
around about 2003, 2004,
long before I
joined the company.
So it began as a sort of
small-scale activity with about
three or four people
in collaboration
with a new version
of our search engine.
So they grew up together.
Each built on little
features of the other,
and [INAUDIBLE] that was used
as initial deployment partner.
And from then, people realized
it was just really helpful
for doing a bunch
of stuff, so they
could focus on what it was they
were trying to do in the search
tools, and the
underlying system would
cope with a bunch of
stuff that they didn't
want to have to deal with.
And that was useful not
only for the search team,
but for other folk as well.
So it's started getting
widespread adoption.
MARK MANDEL: And credit
where credit's due, your name
is on the Borg paper.
JOHN WILKES: So
I wrote the paper
with a bunch of
other collaborators
who did a bunch of work
and experimentation
about the system that many,
many other people had built.
So I'm one of a
huge team of folk
who've done the actual work.
I'm just a guy who ends up being
the poor person talking out
in the front.
But the people who constructed
the system, they run it,
they keep on developing
it right now.
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
So I guess that
means that if you're
someone who's used to
Maps, or Search, or Gmail,
anything even above JCP
in Google cloud platform,
you've used Borg.
JOHN WILKES: Exactly.
With luck, you haven't known it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
So for the people that have
never heard about Borg,
how would you describe it?
What does it do?
JOHN WILKES: It
basically means you
don't have to worry about which
machines you're running on.
So you write-- let's say
you're a Gmail developer.
So you're interested in a next
version of the Gmail service.
So you build a version that.
You try it out.
Typically, you can
test it in our world,
either on your local machine,
or in some Cloud test systems,
and then you just say, great,
let's run that on Borg.
And that's it.
And you say, can
I have 400 copies?
They say, sure.
And that's all you have
to think about, really,
provided you run and jump
through a few other hoops
we'll get to in a minute.
But you don't have
to worry about where
those machines come from.
You don't have to worry
about what other things are
running on the same machine.
You don't have to worry about
if your task falls over,
and you need to be restarted.
All of that stuff just
gets taken care of for you.
It ties in with things
like the security system.
It ties in with
the storage system.
So it gives you access
to data elsewhere.
It ties in with our internal
network and communication
system.
So you can communicate
it inside the company
and also through
the outside world
in a secure fashion in a way
that everything is encrypted
pretty much in flight.
And it just relieves a bunch
of pressure and tension
from the developers
so they can focus
on adding the business value
that they're interested in.
MARK MANDEL: So you're trying
to tell me that people at Google
aren't just, like,
SSH-ing into machines
and just copying
binaries across?
JOHN WILKES: Pretty much.
One of the things
that Borg helps with
is to make sure that
the only time you
can SSH into a machine, you have
to go through a binary, which
we provide that makes sure
that you have a reason
to be on that machine, that
there is some part of something
that you have authority
to access that
is running on that machine.
Otherwise, the answer is nope.
MARK MANDEL: Nope. yeah.
No, that's very cool.
Having looked at-- and I'll
reference this probably a lot,
there was a particular
presentation
you gave at dotScale,
where you wrote,
like, a declarative file.
And you were showing how to
do "hello world" at Scale
with something like 10,000
copies or something ridiculous.
What sort of stuff would you
end up putting inside that?
So I'm guessing you
had, like, a name,
and there's a binary
you want to run?
Something like that?
JOHN WILKES: Pretty much.
So imagine you've
compiled "Hello world"
to run on your local desktop.
So you bring it up to
make sure it works,
and it displays "Hello,
world" in an exciting fashion
in a local screen.
And then you wrap it
with a description
about what you would
like to be true
when it is running on Borg.
And I use those terms carefully.
So you say, first
of all, I've got
to give it a name of some kind.
So we call a collection of tasks
running the same thing, a job.
So a job has a name, [INAUDIBLE]
texturing, and username,
and things like that.
You say where you
want to run it.
And typically you say a cell
which, for us, is median size
cell is about 10,000 machines.
We have them scattered
pretty much all the way
across the globe.
If you go to your
favorite search engine,
you'll be able to find a map of
where Google data centers live.
Each of those runs,
typically, several cells.
And you get to pick
one for various reasons
to do with allocation
policies on the next level up.
You choose, you say,
I want to be there.
You say, here's the program
I've written, "Hello, world"
in this case.
You provide a path
to access that.
If you want to,
you can say things
like how many CPU
calls it might need,
or how many resources it
should consume in terms of RAM,
disk space, things like that.
Or you can say,
ah, choose for me.
Let the system do
that, because we have
a technique for doing that.
And then you say how
many copies you want.
You can start with one.
And the maximum you're allowed
in any one place is 10,000.
So I did a quick demo of running
10,000 copies of "Hello, world"
because why not?
MARK MANDEL: Why not.
JOHN WILKES: Exactly.
And it took about
2 and 1/2 minutes
to get from 0 to
10,000 copies, roughly.
MARK MANDEL: You kind of slipped
something in there, where you
said, it would likely to be.
JOHN WILKES: Oh, you noticed.
MARK MANDEL: I did.
So it's not just saying, oh, I
want 10,000, so I get 10,000.
It's something
slightly different.
So we have this notion of
things failing all the time.
I'm on record as saying that the
reason Google looks like it's
up from the outside is that we
assume the world is collapsing
around our ears on the
inside and write software
to cope for that happening.
So one of the techniques
that we use for that
is what we call those little
declarative statements
about truth and
then reconciliation.
So here, we have a
statement which says,
I would like 10,000
copies of "Hello, world"
running somewhere.
And you send this off
to the Borg master
and the Borg master
compares that with what
is actually the state of the
world and goes, that's funny.
Nobody's placed 10,000
copies of "Hello, world."
So let me fix that.
So a component inside
the Borg master scheduler
goes and starts looking for
places for those 10,000 copies.
And remembers this fact, so the
other thing I need to point out
is that what you
want to write down
do your intentions,
your declarations,
in a way that is
super resilient.
So Borg master
uses a [INAUDIBLE],
which a distributed
fault tolerant
library implementation.
So every copy of the Borg
master has a copy of this state,
and there are five
copies in any one cell.
So if any one of
them comes down,
the others can pick up and carry
on, or at least another one
can pick up and carry on.
So you first of all write
down your intention--
I want 10,000 copies.
And then the scheduler
goes and picks off
a few of these at a time and
finds places for them to run,
spare machines in the
cell-- or, more likely,
a fraction of the spare
machines somewhere in the cell.
And it writes down his decision.
Machine number 17 has a copy.
Machine number 423 has a copy.
And that also gets written out
in a persistent, declarative
fashion.
So if the scheduler
falls over, you
can pick up and carry
on where you left off.
And then, finally,
what happens is
that the Borg master itself
has a component which
compares the state of
the world on the machines
in that cell to what it
thinks should be true.
That's funny, that
machine is supposed
to have a copy of
this "Hello, world,"
but it doesn't have one.
Let me fix that.
And it goes ahead and tells an
agent sitting on that machine
to go grab itself a
copy of "Hello, world"
and start running it.
So that loop of comparing the
outside world against what
you want to be true turns out
to be remarkably resilient
in case of failures.
You can sort of fall over
anywhere in the process
and then pick up from where
you left off and sort of just
get back to where
you want to be.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very interesting.
That means that, at the
beginning, we're going to say,
oh, we're missing 10,000 copies.
But then later on, we're going
to be, we have, like, 9,000.
We're missing only 1,000.
And at what point do we
consider [INAUDIBLE] stable?
And how long-- like you said, 2
minutes and a half for 10,000?
JOHN WILKES: So it took from
zero to 2 and 1/2 minutes
to get up to almost 10,000.
And it turns out that the
Borg master is always trying
to make 10,000 copies running.
But typically it happens
that there's a few of them.
And when I was looking, I
saw about seven to 10 of them
were not running,
even in steady state.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Is that just
a problem because you
have 10,000 of them?
Or is there something actively
saying, no, maybe, "Hello,
world" isn't the most
useful thing in the world
to be running 10,000 copies of?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is
important to say hi, though.
JOHN WILKES: My "Hello, world?"
Are you crazy?
MARK MANDEL: I understand.
JOHN WILKES: Of
course it's important.
I'm giving demo.
No, it turns out,
actually, "Hello, world"
was the least important
thing in the system.
And that matters for
what I'm about to say.
Things go wrong all the time.
Occasionally, machines break.
When you've got 10,000
of them in a cell,
they will actually break
at a break at a fair clip,
in absolute terms.
But in relative terms, these
things are amazingly reliable.
They'll stay up for
quite a long time.
However, we will take
the operating system
down roughly once
a month in order
to do a software upgrade--
maybe because we've
got a better version of
kernel, or maybe we're
rolling out some security
update-- all sorts
of good reasons for doing this.
When you take the
operating system down,
you basically have to
reboot the machine.
And to reboot the machine,
all the stuff that
was running on it is
going to have a bad time.
So that basically is
the primary driver
if you're a production task--
imagine, something like Gmail,
or Google Docs, or Google
cloud platform products.
Those things we'll see an
outage roughly once a month
if they are running
all the time.
That's OK for them,
because they're
used to having other
copies somewhere else.
So it's not a problem.
You just write software
to cope with the fact
that it's going to go away.
But it means that there is
a sort of slow, gentle churn
of things being removed.
Now that's for what we call
production stuff, which
is the things we
really care about.
We have other things, like batch
jobs, which are less important,
or at least maybe they're
more tolerant of things
going wrong-- is the
way to think of it.
And because they are more
tolerant-- if a MapReduce loses
the work, that's fine.
There's plenty more
where that one came from.
And maybe we'll bring this
one back and get another copy.
And maybe it'll be
delayed a second or so.
Eh, no big deal, if it's
running for six hours.
It gives them more flexibility.
So we'll actually allow them
to get pushed out of the way
if we need space for
production tasks to run.
So if you're a production
task, you have high priority.
If you have high priority,
and there's a low priority
thing in your way, you win.
The low priority
thing gets bumped off.
A task dies.
And it will get
started somewhere else,
if there's room.
That's fine.
And you know, there's
this priority order.
It goes from sort of 200 issues
where we run production stuff,
down to zero, which is the
lowest of the low, which
is where "Hello,
world" was running.
So if any other task in the
system needed a resource that
my "Hello, world" was sitting
on, "Hello, " got moved.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Goodbye "Hello, world."
JOHN WILKES: Goodbye
"Hello, world."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very cool.
So most of the things that
you've been talking about I
have the impression that were
limited to a single cell.
Is there one Borg per cell?
Is the Borg in all of the cells?
How does that work?
JOHN WILKES: Oh, this might
be a great point to say,
this Borg is an
internal code name.
It's not an external trade name.
The lawyers can be
happy about this.
So it's just an
internal code name.
We try to avoid the Borg and the
associations that go with that.
Sorry, bad choice of name,
before my time, not my fault.
I talked about we have a fleet.
I'm not going to say
how big, but it's big.
We divide it up into chunks.
Those chunks are
designed to be big enough
to run some of the largest
applications we need to run
but small enough that, if you
lose an entire chunk because, I
don't know, software bug, or
one of our site reliability
engineers mistypes the name
of one of these things,
then it's actually not too bad.
Which is why 10,000 is
an interesting number.
It's big enough to be able to
get a lot of work done in one
place, and it's small enough
that you can have two or three
copies of your application
running in different places.
So one of the reasons why
these Borg clumps, these cells,
are the size they are is
to allow sort of failures
and to bound the
scope of a mistake.
The other is so you can do
things like software updates.
Take them down, bring
them back up again.
So the thing is designed to
cope with pretty much anything
disappearing at any moment.
For example, if the Borg
master has a software bug
and disappears, all
the stuff that's
working in the cell
right now stays working.
It doesn't stop.
And the agents on
each of the machines
that will trying to
contact to keep trying.
And eventually,
it will come back,
and they'll just pick
up where they left off.
So in the meantime,
they'll just keep
working on what it was
they were last asked to do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we
kind of keep going around
it and talking about it.
I kind of want to highlight it
as a really interesting point
that everything is
built for failure,
like it an assumption
of failure.
Everything will
break at some point.
And I think that's a really
interesting like software
development practice to start
from, like, everything is bad.
Rather than, in
an ideal scenario,
the server will be up forever.
I think that's really,
really interesting.
JOHN WILKES: So a lot of
the design discussions
that I get involved
in are around,
what happens when that
fails while you're
doing this other thing?
Have you made a slightly
flaky assumption
that it's going to be OK because
it's going to keep working?
I was in a room one time
listening to a talk of somebody
describing one of
our internal systems,
and he was sort of skating
over one of these areas.
And there were 50 or
60 people in the room.
And somebody asked
him a question
about a particular thing.
It turned out that
they'd allowed
a [? raised ?]
condition to happen,
and there was a point
where it could go wrong.
And I think about a third
of the people in the room
put their hand up at that
point simultaneously and said,
just a minute.
MARK MANDEL: No, no.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wait a minute.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
So that's really interesting.
So you've got this
declarative syntax.
You tell your system
what it is you want.
That means you have to have
a lot of trust in the system
that you're running on.
How does that get verified?
Or do you just trust it,
and you're like, it's fine?
But I mean, you're
building for failure.
So how does that work?
JOHN WILKES: There's a slogan
which really works here.
If you're not measuring
it, it is out of control.
So trust, but verify.
We do put a lot of effort
into designing systems
to be failure tolerant,
including the systems that
run the systems
that are designed
to be failure
tolerant, and so on,
all the way up and
down the stack.
But you want to make
sure that it is.
You actually need to measure it.
So we put a huge
amount of resources
into monitoring the
systems that we have,
including the systems that are
monitoring the systems we have.
And they will report
things like, this
is what I was expecting to see.
This is what I'm
currently seeing.
And if they differ in
the wrong way around,
then you fire off alerts
and get people involved.
People are always at
the top of the stack.
People can do things that
no machine can ever do.
But you want to have
the machine automate
the process of doing the
regular straightforward stuff.
For example, we're
talking only about sort
of tasks being killed or pushed
off a machine, this is normal.
You don't have to write
special code to handle
this as an unusual exception.
This happens all the time.
So you write the software to
have that happen all the time,
and then you move on.
And then you check
that, in fact,
if you asked for
100 copies of it,
you got close to
100 copies running.
But there is a
monitoring system which
is keeping an eye on that,
and displaying it, and telling
eventually a human,
or maybe [INAUDIBLE]
another intermediate
system, that you
have fewer than you expected.
Now, to make that
work, the people
who write the software
on which you rely
typically have to tell you
how much you can rely on it.
So we have internal
specifications
of how often things break.
For example, we have a sort
of rate limit, or rather
an expectation,
of how frequently
your tasks can be removed.
So you write your software
assuming that that rate is
probably going to be net.
And then we have the site
reliability engineers
who run these systems.
And they're spectacularly
good at making
sure the systems both
do what they're supposed
to do and do it within spec.
And they invoke
fixes and do whatever
they need to do if it
turns out the system is not
behaving as it should be.
And the only way they know that
is if they're monitoring it
and keep an eye on it.
But that gives you
a handle on design.
So you know that there's no
unbounded limit at which things
are going to go bad.
We will tell you, here is
a plausible upper bound
on how bad things could be,
and write software around
according to that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So that is actually
something very interesting.
Is that what, at
bigger scale, becomes
what we call an SLA, a
Service Level Agreement?
JOHN WILKES: Well, it becomes
the SLO part of the SLA.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: SLO, yeah.
JOHN WILKES: Right,
so just terminology,
for [INAUDIBLE],
Service Level Objective.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
JOHN WILKES: The way
I think of it is,
something I want to be true.
I'd love there to be no more
than about this many failures
per week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
something that I thought
was pretty amazing when I
was reading the SRE book,
it was about SLO's and how,
if we are having our SLO
is higher than
expected, sometimes we
will just make our
services fail just for fun.
JOHN WILKES: For two reasons.
Well, some people
might do it for fun.
MARK MANDEL: Some people just
want to watch the world burn.
JOHN WILKES: Exactly.
[JOKER LAUGH]
There's a couple of reasons.
Sometimes you find people
mistakenly assuming something
is going to be up.
Because it always has been
whenever they've looked.
Well, if it turns
out it might not be,
and they've made an assumption
that it is, that's a failure
that they've just
written for themselves.
So, for example, we
have a system internally
we call Chubby, which
we use for storing
relatively small quantities
of information that
is incredibly available.
And we have local versions
of it in every cell,
or pretty much every cell.
And we also have a
global one, which
is more convenient to
access, but we do not
promise it is always there.
So just to make sure that,
if you choose to use it,
you cannot rely on it, the
people who run that service
will deliberately take
it down once a quarter.
And then we find
all those people
who fall over because they were
assuming that old Chubby was
there, and we go fix them
because that's not acceptable.
So that's one reason for why
you might choose to inject
failures-- to find faults.
And the second reason
is that, maybe if you're
making your system
too good, you're
spending too much money on it.
You can maybe economize.
You could maybe
use fewer resources
or maybe have a few
less copies, or be
willing to take the
resources you are putting
into that system to
make it behave well
and move it somewhere else
where it would have more benefit
to a business or a customer.
MARK MANDEL: I guess it's
kind of that whole thing--
it's better to do
it like in training,
or when people are watching,
for a bad thing to happen,
than to have to go,
oh, it's an emergency.
Let's do it right now.
JOHN WILKES: Absolutely.
But you also have to
prepare for emergencies
and be ready to do
it right now, which
is why having people
incredibly good at this running
your systems is the
right way to go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So regarding
that issue of making sure
that things don't rely on
things that could go down,
is it also true that sometimes
we will take down actual data
centers, or things like that--
not just for fun, as we said,
but to make sure that not
like not crazy assumptions
are taken.
JOHN WILKES: So we do
this annual exercise
we call Dirt, where
we, first of all,
begin by assuming that the
company headquarters has slid
into the sea in California
and is disconnected
from the rest of the world.
So can we keep running
Google without Mountain View?
And the answer,
pretty much, is yes.
And then we add some
interesting mix to it.
So my favorite from one year
was that the operations team
in Dublin apparently
went out drinking one day
and wasn't going to be
back for several days.
Another version of
this is, we simulate--
we didn't actually do this.
That would be painful.
It's a simulation.
Let's pretend we have
lost all power to one
of our really big data centers.
And you discover
what's going to happen.
Well, what happened
is, those people go,
good grief, we've got a
bunch of stuff running.
We have diesel generators.
They switch on.
They start burning
through diesel
to keep these things running.
They're producing an
awful lot of power.
And you call up the
local diesel suppliers
and say, give me
trucks full of diesel.
Get them lined up right
now, because we're
going to need to move
them as fast as we
can to keep the things afloat.
And then somebody
says, great, how
are you going to pay for this?
And you say, oh, the people
in Mountain View-- oops.
So that's why you
do these exercises,
is you have a chance to find
out those things in a world
where it isn't
actually a disaster.
You can cope with it ahead of
time and go, let's fix that.
Another example where
something happened was we
discovered we needed to get
everybody on a phone bridge
to be able to talk about it
because we have systems that
are spread across the
globe, and we have
experts in different countries.
And they are panicking
trying to get something done.
And they couldn't
set up a phone bridge
because that relied on a piece
of software that was currently
down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
JOHN WILKES: The fix for that
is quite straightforward.
You always have a phone
bridge ready to go.
And everybody has its
number that needs it.
And off you go.
So those are the kind
of things that you
don't think of until you
go through the process.
And then you go, d'oh, why
didn't I think of that?
As you build up
experience in this,
and I think the SRE book is
a wonderful example of that,
it's basically a distillation
of several thousand people
times a dozen plus
years of experiences
of making or discovering
opportunities
for not screwing up and writing
them down for other people
so we could spread the wealth.
MARK MANDEL: Standing on
the shoulder of giants.
JOHN WILKES: There we go, yes.
MARK MANDEL: So let's
change tack a little bit.
I don't want to go over time,
as much as I want to just
talk to you forever and ever.
We want to talk a little
about the open source
project Kubernetes.
There's definitely direct
influences from Borg,
and what we do at Google
as a whole, to Kubernetes--
I think, specifically
around lessons
around failure, optimization,
trusting your system.
Do you know some history about
how Kubernetes came about?
And I think you
probably heard about it.
What's that connection there?
JOHN WILKES: So
indeed, yes, it was
some people who were associated
with Borg ecosystem who
were involved in its creation.
So it came out as a
combination of sort
of Borg and the cloud
ecosystem that we
were building internally.
And somebody noticed that this
wonderful use of containers, we
use them internally,
we have used them
for a very long
time-- Borg is built
around allocating containers.
They are just are a way of
encapsulating your program
so that it can run
pretty much anywhere.
I talked before about running
on the desktop and then also
being able to move
into Borg universe.
The same thing is now possible
in the external world thanks
to Docker, which
is just a really
nice, tasteful combination of
a bunch of technologies that
were floating around that
somebody went and said,
good grief, if we put
these things together,
we've got essentially
the same idea.
So Docker came out
in the outside world.
And about the same time,
sort of our cloud business
was getting going in
an interesting way.
And we went, ah,
wonderful opportunity
for us to share our
expertise to make
this available to
the larger ecosystem.
So if you've go one instance
of one application running
in one place, then a Docker
container is just fine.
You can launch new copies of it.
You can send it up.
You can test it.
Once you get to about 10,
or 100 of these things,
it gets tedious to
do this by hand.
Hold on, we've done that before.
There's a pattern
we've seen here.
Let's see if we can
replicate that pattern
in the outside world
using off the shelf
software in the open
source community
and make it available
to people so that we
can build an ecosystem and
have everybody contribute
to this so it's not
just a Google project,
it's actually an open
source community that's
been created around the stuff.
We have lots of contributors,
thousands of them
at the last count, trying to
help Kubernetes become better.
Kubernetes is the outcome.
One way of looking
at it is, it's
a sort of Borg Lite version
2 done to try and take
the most important
parts of the lessons
we've learned-- including things
like the failure tolerance.
So Borg uses [INAUDIBLE] for
its internal persistent store.
Kubernetes uses [INAUDIBLE]
to get the same effect.
There's a central place where
you have the master in it,
you say, I wish this to
be true, and the same kind
of protocols that we talked
about before are applied.
There's an agent
[INAUDIBLE] machine
called the Kublet, much
same way that there's
a Borg [INAUDIBLE] machine
in the Borg universe.
So all those ideas
are very similar.
And then we added a
few new ones based
on our experience with Borg.
And we've been running this
thing for a decade or so now.
And we've learned there are
a few things it does that we
wished it didn't.
So let's not impose that
on the outside world.
Only new mistakes.
So that's really how it came.
And it turned out a lot of the
people who are now currently
on the Google portion
of the Kubernetes effort
are ex-Borg people.
They either moved 20
feet down the corridor
or stayed where they were
and then switched projects
and understood they're applying
the expertise they built up
over the years in
the Borg universe
to the Kubernetes space.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that is interesting.
You said that we
could see Kubernetes
as kind of an evolution of
Borg with all the things we
have learned over the years.
What is the biggest difference
you think is worth mentioning?
JOHN WILKES: It's open source.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
That is a very good point.
JOHN WILKES: People
every now and again
ask me, so, why didn't
you open source Borg?
And I sort of look at
them gently and go,
you have no idea of how much of
the internal Google ecosystem
tentacles reach their way
inside our implementation.
We couldn't do it
even if we wanted to.
It's just too hard.
But if you start from scratch,
and if you target being an open
source project, and you
aim for an Apache license,
and you use a different
language to make sure you
don't accidentally have
dependencies on things--
so Borg is in C++.
Kubernetes is in Go-- you end
up with a thing that is actually
far more malleable to the
outside world, which is great.
I mean, that's
what it's all for.
And, as a result, we have many
people contributing to it.
And it's kind of
making rapid progress.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
one of the differences
that I heard was also very
important-- other than open
sourcing or not, was labels.
I've heard that labels is a
thing that is not part of Borg.
Is that true?
And why do you think that
labels were added to Kubernetes?
JOHN WILKES: Because
we actually were
trying to add them for Borg.
And we made progress on it.
We used them in the outside
world, and our Google Cloud
product e-platform.
And they turn out to be
a much more flexible way
of grouping things together.
So Borg has a notion,
which we call a job.
A job just a set of pretty
much identical tasks.
But that's all it has.
It doesn't have any way of
grouping subsets together,
or overlapping subsets,
or those kind of things.
And labels let you do this.
You put a label, any label
you like, on a set of tasks
and then say, do something like,
tell me the performance of it.
Or do an upgrade
on, or take it down,
or bring up a new version, or
et cetera on all the things
for which this set
of labels applies.
So now I have
basically Venn diagram
set like behavior on any
mixture that you like.
And you get to define it.
You don't just have
this one single factor
that is a very constrained
way of doing business.
So that was one of the lessons.
So Borg provided a primitive.
It was helpful, but it
didn't go far enough.
It was a simple new
abstraction of labels
we get to take-- you can
reproduce the behavior we used
to have in Borg, but you
also get all this other stuff
as well.
So that's a win-win.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
that actually makes,
I guess, monitoring easier
because you can monitor per,
really, the tasks
that you care about,
which made me think
about, OK, so you
said that everything
at Google runs
on Borg-- or mostly everything.
JOHN WILKES: Mostly everything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
that, to make sure
that Borg is working
correctly, we have monitoring.
Does the monitoring
for Borg run on Borg?
JOHN WILKES: Good question.
Yes, it does.
So the monitoring systems
are jobs that Borg runs.
But remember, I told you, if
the Borg master goes down,
the systems it was
running stay up.
There's no reason
why they should stop.
And you can also monitor
one Borg cell from another.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Interesting.
JOHN WILKES: So actually so
one of the interesting projects
underway at the
moment is to say,
what would happen if we
turned off all of Google
and tried to boot
it up from scratch.
MARK MANDEL: Oh god.
JOHN WILKES: Because the
standard way of booting up
a new cell is to go grab a
bunch of stuff from another one
because it's up there.
MARK MANDEL: But if you
don't have another other cell
to go to, where do you go?
JOHN WILKES: Yes, so exactly.
So this is the kind of thinking
where somebody starts going,
let's talk about failure
modes we haven't thought
about before, which goes back
to one of our earlier topics.
Imagine the worst case.
No, no, the worst case.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Really
the worst case, wow.
MARK MANDEL: That
almost comes back to,
like, we were talking
about communities directly,
like federated communities, and
being able to do cross cloud.
And it's like, OK, yeah,
we have this cluster of 10,
50, 100, 1,000 machines.
That's great.
What if that data
center goes down?
Or what if that cloud
provider goes down?
Or what if my
on-premise-- like, I
want it to be in
multiple places at once.
Let's think about that
as a failure scenario.
JOHN WILKES: And it also gives
you freedom of deployment
that separates the
decision about where
you run from what your
application developers write.
If you have a standard API,
like the Kubernetes one,
you get to write to this API.
And you can run exactly
the same thing locally.
You can run it on premises
in your own data center
if you want.
You can run it on
cloud provider one,
cloud provider two, or maybe
a mix of all of these things.
And you can change
your mind at any time.
You're not bound to
one of those things.
So that freedom of
flexibility in deployment
is a wonderful thing that
Kubernetes gives you.
MARK MANDEL: Unfortunately,
we are running out of time.
I'm dreadfully disappointed.
Is there anything that
we haven't touched on,
or you want to mention, or talk
about, or plug, or anything
like that, that we
haven't had time to cover?
JOHN WILKES: Google
Cloud is a wonderful way
of being able to leverage
pretty much a bunch of stuff
like the things I've
been describing.
So you don't have
to do all that work.
I mean, the same freedom that
we give internal developers is
that part of the message behind
things like the cloud products.
So you can rely on stuff.
I was in Illinois
giving a talk last week
about some of our data
flow and storage products.
And in the middle of it, I was
able to do a live demo of doing
a search in petabyte table.
It took about 12 seconds.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
JOHN WILKES: That's
the kind of thing
you want to be able
to take advantage
of to get your job done.
You shouldn't have to be
worrying about building
the infrastructure to do that.
So this is the
story behind Borg.
It's the story behind
the Kubernetes.
And it's the story behind the
entire Google cloud product
line.
Focus on what you can bring
and add value to, and then
build on best in class
implementations of stuff
underneath you can
get from other people.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
I have one more question.
So you've been working on
Borg for quite a while.
Can you share what
are you working on?
Like, what is the
next crazy thing
you're going to
be working about?
If we interview you in a couple
years what would we talk about?
JOHN WILKES: That's a great
question I'm going to duck.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
MARK MANDEL: So you know what?
You know that means?
A couple years from now,
we'll grab John again,
and we'll interview
him once more.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That sounds good.
JOHN WILKES: I'd love that.
This was fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you very much.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you very much.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
thanks so much again
to John Wilkes for such
an interesting episode.
I was so sad that
the time ran over.
I want to have him again.
MARK MANDEL: We could
talk to him for days.
Days and days and day.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, very
interesting conversation.
I don't know.
I think that I learned a lot.
We will have a bunch of
links, especially to the talk
he gave at dotScale.
I think that is a very
good talk to watch through
to understand a little bit more
about what we're talking about.
But yeah.
He's amazing.
So again, thanks
so much for coming.
So I think it's time to go
with the question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I think this
is a really interesting one.
So within the SDKs we
provide for Google Cloud
for accessing services that
we have, like say, maybe data
store, or authentication,
or storage,
stuff like that, we have a thing
in there called application
default credentials.
And that makes it really easy.
So if I've got, say,
some code, maybe it's
running on an app engine, or
GCE, I can defautly just go,
OK, I know that you're
running on GCE, which
is internal to our
project, so you
don't have to do
anything special
to authenticate to log in to,
like, a particular service.
And that's great.
That's dandy.
That's awesome.
What do I do if I'm
testing locally,
but I want to be able to connect
to that thing in the cloud
that I would do normally?
Is there an easy way?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, so
the important thing to know
is that the way this
works is by accessing
some URL that is only
accessible from inside
of your own network.
So if you're running it
locally, fortunately, you
don't have access to
that because security.
So the only way of
doing this before
was to download a JSON file--
so go create a new service
account on the console, and
then download that file,
put it in a good place,
and then make sure
that you have the correct global
variable, environment variable,
pointing to that JSON file.
MARK MANDEL: Ow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: My brain now hurts.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Now,
you can do a gcloud beta
of application default login.
That's it.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, and that
just grabs the thing it needs,
does the magic, and
it suddenly works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it does all the magic.
So basically, if you have a
call to get application default
credential from your
code, it will just work.
MARK MANDEL: That's really cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is pretty amazing.
I've used it a couple times.
And I was surprised
because I really expected,
oh, so what is its next step.
And its next step is your done.
So, yay.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So
that's really cool.
It means, then, you can
be like sometimes maybe
if you want to use an
emulator, if that's available,
you can do that.
Or you can connect
to the service that's
actually in the
cloud, and you have
really easy ways of doing both.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, as we mentioned
in a previous episode,
there are some emulators,
like data store has a emulator
for it, which is really cool.
But some of the services do
not have those emulators.
And sometimes you
don't want to emulate,
you actually want to talk to
the service, the real service.
And doing the authentication
in those cases
can be a little bit hard.
So yeah, that way you can
run your test directly
on your laptop, which is on a
completely different network,
without having any other
issues-- which is awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, why don't
we tease a little
what we're going to be
talking about the next couple
of episodes, because we
do have those lined up?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so one of the topic's
going to be cloud abuse.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, so, possibly,
if there is anything bad
happening on your account, or
doing anything that possibly
breaks terms of service?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, basically,
what are the things
you should avoid doing,
and what happens if
someone is somehow
hacking you and doing those?
You will get a
notice saying, hey,
something weird is going on.
What do you do?
So very interesting topic.
And most of the things
are related to, well, you
got hacked.
Like somehow, someone got
access to your instances,
and they're doing something
that they should not be doing.
So the episode
right after is going
to be about how do
I secure my network,
basically, so networking
on Google cloud platform.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, some--
two really good conversations
which I should
definitely listen in for.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I'm
pretty excited about those.
They're pretty pragmatic.
They're like, OK,
so this happened.
What do you do next?
MARK MANDEL: What
do you do next?
Worst case scenario type
stuff, which is great.
So I know you're out and about
a bit over the next week or so.
I think when this episode comes
out, you'll be in New York.
Is that right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So when
this episode comes out,
I will be in New York.
And actually, I'll
be probably only away
to go to the
Economist, where we'll
be running Learn How to Build
High Scalable Web Apps with Go
workshop hosted by Women Who Go.
But if you want to join,
this is open to anyone.
So feel free to check out
the show notes and join.
And if you cannot go,
it is totally fine.
Because on Monday,
I will be running
basically the same thing
but on a Go remote meetup.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds like lots of fun.
I have looked at that workshop.
It's a lot of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, because
it's about to be open sourced.
Yay.
Soon, soon.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: The day after
this episode comes out,
I will be at Siege in Atlanta.
I'm particularly
excited about that
because they said, oh,
we'll give you four minutes
to rant about whatever you
like in regards to the games
industry.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: And I
like complaining.
It's lots of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Developer advocate.
MARK MANDEL: Developer advocate.
So yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Professional whiner.
MARK MANDEL: So I am actually
complaining about people
not being able to talk
about their games.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Very interesting.
MARK MANDEL: So that will
be lots and lots of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool, so
yeah, if you are anywhere
where you can find
us, don't forget
that we do have stickers.
MARK MANDEL: Stickers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So come get them.
I think that we have
not done these for ages,
so why don't we remind everyone
how to get in touch with us?
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
So what's the website?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Gcppodcast.com
or cloud.google.com/podcast.
MARK MANDEL: If people
want to e-mail us?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Don't.
No, hello@gcpodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Subreddit?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: R/gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Google+?
Plus?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: +gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Twitter?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: @gcppodcast.
MARK MANDEL: Slack?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's a
Podcast channel in their Google
cloud platform community.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Channel.
Community.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, no,
no, yeah, you got it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I got it.
MARK MANDEL: You got it.
Did I miss anything?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I feel
like you forgot something.
But I don't know which one.
MARK MANDEL: I don't think so.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So anyway,
get in touch with us.
Send us your
questions of the week.
Send us any question, or
any cool thing of the week
that you think we should share.
Just let us know.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, actually, you
know what would be really cool?
If somebody sent us an audio
recording of their question.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Ooh, that'd be cool.
Yes, do that.
Record your own audio asking a
question and e-mail it to us.
That'd be awesome.
Or tweet it, or whatever.
MARK MANDEL: We'll find a way.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
That's a great idea, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: You're welcome.
So yeah.
Waiting for those.
And talk to you, Mark, and
talk to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.